[Musique]
marina vous êtes encore très jeune et
vous avez déjà pas mal vous avez fait
pas mal de petites bêtises on vous a vue
sur instagram avec une cigarette à la
main dans une interview vous avez
également confié bon de temps en temps
fumer une petite chose par ci par là ben
j'vais vous lister des bêtises et tous
vous allez prendre votre port carte et
vous me dites si vous l'avez fait ou pas
et on va voir si marina nous en dit de
nouvelles qui a déjà fait semblant
d'être malade pour ne pas aller en cours
et cela est déjà fait sa marine a déjà
fait vous racontiez à l'époque ben rien
de spécial jeu et on sait chez beaucoup
les cours à la fin pas mal oui d'accord
mais vous casser les oreilles moi je
mettais le terme est sûre le lampe au
delà la lampe de chevet comme ça ça
monte à 40 41 et rêvait pas en cours
elle a pour but et boukari volant pour
vous et loire savoie
[Applaudissements]
vous avez une technique il fallait
mettre des peaux d'orange dans des
chaussettes pour faire monter la
température
sa voix çà n'est pas un mode aurait
ensuite on va passer doc est la suivante
ce qui a déjà volé quelque chose dans un
magasin n'est pas pour autant un voleur
une petite bricole quand on est petit
jamais fait alors non vous avez déjà
fait vos carreaux énormément je me suis
même fait arrêter par les lignes et on
passe pour s'aperçoit au fait que fait
partie du gros banditisme
je n'ai réussi en dépit de mes soeurs et
féret que nous et la compet vraiment
pendant un petit moment de celle qui
devrait le plus et on s'est fait choper
aux galeries lafayette faisaient voler
que c'est vrai ouais commissariat appel
aux parents et non c'était pas moi je
voulais pas vous le faites pas parce que
ça a évité depuis six mois je voulais
pas grand chose c'était des petits
malabar de carambar dans les
boulangeries qui vole un oeuf vole un
boeuf balma tu vois j'ai encore pas volé
un boeuf
celle là je le connais que on savait pas
ce qui allait sortir mais on s'attendait
pas à ça elle a mouché tout le monde qui
a déjà fait le mur pour sortir en boîte
ça c'est pas bien ça dit la vérité elle
si vous avez chaîne a fait le mur n'ont
jamais vous êtes passé par la fenêtre
sans dire à vos parents ont commencé à
aller en boîte à 18 ans bon et vous
cassany ouais bah oui ça m'est arrivé
très souvent fait qu'il ait inventé lui
défoncer le mur je passais par là elle
par la gouttière je descendais qu'est ce
que vous avez déjà fait le mur moi j'ai
menti j'ai dit je dois veut garder des
enfants je vais faire du baby-sitting
s'il te plaît trois sorties il faut que
gardez-vous viennent des sous j'y suis
allé et en fait je suis allé en boîte
avec des copines et je me suis cassé la
figure en scooter j'ai fini une semaine
à l'hôpital et que sont devenus les
enfants à bord mais ne s'est jamais
garder et je n'avais pas en fait ça
n'existe pas
conférence
qui a déjà télécharger un album de
marina qu'est illégalement selva savent
également moins également non illégal
légale en version ebook rassurez vous
c'est pas ici et pas nous c'est pas nous
qui vous posons des problèmes qui a déjà
passé une soirée en garde à vue personne
ne donnait corps la même chose même
palais jusqu'au bout quel 28 20
personnes avec une vitre est allé on
entre chez nous
[Applaudissements]